Okay,
let's go to work.
Um,
violating the syllabus.
I've retitled today's discussion from Marxists to stores.
Historicism to Howard heads tennis racket.
And let's begin with Howard heads tennis racket.
Howard head was a,
um,
an alum of Harvard College,
uh,
a bright guy
and a not very good,
uh,
airframe engineer.
He was a second class designer of the details of airplanes for Mcdonnell Douglas
Corporation.
And he was an avid skier and an avid,
but very untalented tennis player.
And as he tells the story,
there was a night on a bus,
a motor coach,
to use his words,
uh,
bringing him,
back to New York from Vermont,
from Stowe.
And he'd had a rough weekend of skiing.
And he said,
what would happen if we took the aluminum wafer with which we're building
airplanes and made a ski from it.
And sure enough,
he did that.
And the skiing industry,
not just the sale of skis,
but the total size of the skiing market was transformed forever because skiing
now became more fun and vastly easier.
Uh,
five years later,
uh,
he had the same,
he applied the same thought process to tennis rackets at the time the world
market in tennis rackets had converged on the Bancroft,
uh,
wooden racket,
a name for Jack Kramer who died in his own bed is in the times this morning.
Uh,
and everybody was competing on price and details of quality with the wooden
racket.
And there were no rules about how big a racket could be.
And it occurred to head that if he substituted in the bow of the racket,
substituted aluminum for wood,
the structural properties of aluminum would allow the head of the racket to be
much bigger.
Uh,
do any of you play with giant tennis rackets?
I know it's a point of pride among really good players not to do that.
Mine I,
I retired from tennis three or four years ago,
but my,
at my retirement was about like that and it makes Tennessee's and it created a
mass market and it redefined the whole business.
Now the idea of creative destruction,
which is usually about things more complicated than skiing and tennis.
Uh,
the whole idea of creative destruction is that the process of competing to sell
the best product at the lowest price within the given market framework often
does it indeed lead to something like monopoly or at least oligopoly and uh,
a point made at length by Marxists,
critics of capitalism.
But as the,
as that happens,
it,
it occurs over and over and over again.
That's somebody like Howard head finds an alternative technology in variably
aimed not at luxury markets aimed at regular people and very seldom aimed at a
corporate or governmental buyers,
but again at private sector buyers and generates with that product an entirely
new market,
shatters the equilibrium,
hits it with a hammer.
And this thought is on the one hand antagonistic to marks that is,
it is a way of refuting Marx's idea about monopoly capitalism.
On the other hand,
it is exactly in the spirit of young marks,
the young Marx we hear in the communist manifesto,
red for today's assignment,
who saw capitalism as an enormously productive system,
which was incapable of standing still,
which was always leaning forward into the wind,
which was do you Schumpeter's term?
Nothing more than a mechanism for economic change.
According to Schumpeter.
The very essence of capitalism is that an s is a system always in the process of
revising itself.
It is never capable of standing still.
And Young Marx certainly believed just about that same thing and believed that
the productive forces,
I'm remember he's writing in 1847 1848 that the productive forces associated
with capitalism were unprecedented in world history.
And May I call on one of your classmates to read the pivotal paragraph from that
work?
Uh
Huh.
Every last damn certainty in education.
The same support from all over your room.
All frozen relationships with that train of ancient is mineral questions are
sort of the way our new from the ones that come antiquated when you put them all
of the solid and all that is holy.
It's propane and man it did last compelled to face and some are sentence.
The real conditions of life and his relationship is kind of,
thank you very much.
Okay.
So Mark's is,
they're talking about the,
at the time he's writing a railroads are just beginning to transform the
European world around him.
Steam ships are a generation and a half into transforming world commerce.
The use of a newly efficient steam engines in manufacturing is creating ever
cheaper goods.
The market in world tech styles has driven the price of ordinary cotton cloth,
uh,
nearly to zero so that nearly everyone in the market,
advanced market societies can afford to dress more or less the way all of you
are dressed.
Uh,
that is to say,
well,
whatever,
look around.
Uh,
but the point is that the,
the revolutionary transformation of the means of production and of what is
produced and at what cost itself is very much on marks as mine.
Additionally,
Europe is politically unstable in the 1840s and there are five or six nodes of
apparent revolutionary activity stretching from,
uh,
Austria through Germany into czarist,
Russia.
And Mark's imagines that his relatively abstract analysis of capitalism is
scientific.
And by scientific,
he means that it has predictive force,
that his science of economy and society is so powerful that it allows him to
foresee the future.
Not to foresee the exact dates and details of future history,
but that the broad outlines are beyond human control.
So there are actually two assertions here.
One is that the world's history is determined that it is like the machinery of
the heavens.
It is like the planets revolving around the a good astronomer can readily
predict the phases of the moon,
the occurrence of eclipses,
all those things,
and that science,
which was in the past by Marxists time and which he saw he,
he has aspired to that level of confidence.
And we're going to look at his historicism.
That is the double belief that the world is deterministic and that he and his
associates can actually unlock the keys to the future under six headings,
the first of which is monopoly capitalism and will we will take that up
momentarily.
Second is the proposition that in the long run,
the rate of profit for capitalist enterprises has to fall,
uh,
third,
the immiseration of the working class that as profits fall.
So does the wage stream available to the working class?
So both the capitalists and they're adversaries in the proletariat face,
a squeezing vice,
which takes their discretionary power out of the system,
uh,
as the vice squeezes revolution becomes inevitable.
That's the fourth point on the,
or the third point on the chart.
Uh,
the fourth point is Mark's is
I'm a great respecter of Marx's Brennan's,
uh,
but the,
the,
the theory of the universal class is almost childlike.
And the idea is that if you search out the bottom of the bottom of the bottom
classes,
then that class will have the unique property that it has no one else to
exploit.
And if it has no one else to exploit,
then there won't be exploitation.
And since the purpose of the state is to defend the interest of an exploiting
class,
then the state will become unnecessary and will as the bottom line says here,
wither away.
Now
the the many decades
of experience,
we have lead us to be a friendly critics toward the top of this story and
unfriendly critics toward the bottom because the story told that the bottom is
not only a false,
uh,
but dangerous.
Yeah.
Okay.
Monopoly capitalism.
You'll remember that I,
when I was sitting with Jim Alexander last class,
uh,
talking about Adam Smith and the conditions under which the invisible hand
remains invisible.
I used the porter forces commonly used in Mba,
uh,
instruction,
to define the opposite of each of the conditions,
uh,
put forward by Smith.
And so I'm using them again here and in a monopoly capitalist situation,
the monopolistic from,
uh,
has eliminated direct competition or rendered it trivial.
Uh,
it has,
it has caused the erection of high barriers to entry so that as its profits
increase and other say,
what a good idea.
Let's get into that business.
It has ways of keeping them out or once they come in of punishing them,
uh,
to the point of bankruptcy.
A third,
these are products that are not discretionary.
They're hard to substitute for.
You can't have a serious monopoly in children's games.
You can't have a serious monopoly in a given fragrance of aftershave lotion or
of perfume.
Serious monopolies are in,
are always in things which people need and for which they don't readily find
substitutes.
Uh,
the firm is vertically integrated and,
uh,
by by vertical integration,
I mean,
think about starting,
well,
let's take,
take the laptop in front of you.
Uh,
starting with the aluminum,
the silica
metal wires,
all that stuff.
Starting with raw materials that are in the earth,
extracting those,
designing them,
fabricating them,
marketing the machine,
distributing the machine.
That whole long trail of production from raw materials at the one end to finish
product in the hand of a Bot,
hands of a buyer at the other vertical integration in the extreme means that the
corporation controls that whole sweep.
The part that reaches from manufacturing towards the buyer is called forward
integration.
The part that reaches from the manufacturer back to raw materials.
It's called backward integration.
But this pattern of integration gives the company great power because there are
no suppliers who can hold up the firm for a part,
a part of its profits.
Buyers don't have leverage to control prices.
Uh,
competitors can't manufacture a very similar machine,
20% cheaper and drive down profits and people in substitute industries don't
have any way of drawing away customers.
So that's the,
I'm caricaturing,
uh,
but things which more or less fit that description historically would be.
For example,
standard oil,
John D Rockefeller who controlled,
who came into control of oil all the way from exploration and the wellhead,
uh,
through refining and distribution,
he came to control the railroads which his rivals would need to use to
distribute their product and managed to use the railroads to impose a
artificially high freight prices on his competitors so that he was able in
effect to monopolize the whole industry.
The US steel.
A similar story.
This would,
this,
this would be Andrew Carnegie,
a Microsoft.
There are there,
there has been a long debate about,
about antitrust for Microsoft and um,
it's pretty close to a monopoly.
It's,
I look around the room and I see little white apples illuminated everywhere.
And
I have one myself.
Um,
my eldest daughter is a partner level executive at Microsoft and in her house,
our apple computers,
which I have given her family.
Um,
uh,
another kind,
another story of the same instance is the regulated airlines,
regulated airlines.
This is before the late seventies,
when the airlines were deregulated,
would own a route and monopolize it and they would compete,
uh,
not on the basis of price because they would charge monopoly prices.
They would compete on the basis of food and attractive flight attendants.
And there are,
I'm not going near that,
uh,
the big pharmaceuticals or Pharma's,
are,
uh,
sometimes in monopolistic or near monopolistic positions about drugs and many
other cases,
though fewer than the ideological critics of capitalism would make you believe
and fewer partly because of creative destruction as monopolies.
Ossify people find ways to blow them up.
Okay,
so let's try,
let's talk about that.
And on the left side of this little diagram,
we have ways to build a monopoly and on the right side,
ways to burn a monopoly.
And on the vertical we have market forces
and on the horizontal,
the top horizontal,
we have market forces,
the bottom horizontal,
we have governmental forces and let's just get ourselves familiar with the four
resulting cells,
scale and scope.
Um,
mostly scale if there are returns to scale so that each widget gets cheaper to
produce as you produce.
Many of them,
the firm which is producing the largest,
the largest quantities in enjoys and enormous strategic advantage
illustrated here if number of widgets produced is on the horizontal dimension
and the marginal cost of the last widget is vertical being positioned where this
little green company is positioned is an enormous advantage in comparison with a
little orange firms at the left.
The,
these are boutique firms doing very level and the giant producer,
which in the American economy for a very long time was general motors for
example.
Uh,
and it's a general motors and it's an immediate competitors in Ford and
Chrysler.
But if you,
let's,
I'll illustrate the point in,
at the time of the decade before World War One,
there were 1200 automobile manufacturing companies in the United States.
And almost all of them got winkled out by the end of the 1920s,
who were about a dozen at the end of the twenties.
And we're now approaching what number are we going to end up with?
Zero is one real possibility,
uh,
more likely,
I think one,
one and a half,
two,
something like that.
But the eat the scale economies in that kind of business are enormously
important.
Creative destruction.
And here we have Schumpeter again and one way of using Schumpeter is to take a
very long view of dominant,
uh,
technologies for energy and production and look at how they have shifted over
time.
And in this chart,
is that legible for any of you are not?
Not really.
Okay.
Uh,
the,
um,
the chart begins with production based on water,
power on mills based on falling water.
And it turns out historically these were very important.
The first great,
uh,
a great advances in the manufacturer of textiles occurred in plants located
along the fall line of rivers where it was possible to extract a great deal of
energy from falling water and drive mass manufacturing.
Uh,
then a sec,
then you have creative destruction with the emergence of steam and rail as
alternatives.
Uh,
then electricity,
and I won't pause long,
but the great battle of the 1890s was between alternating current electricity
controlled by George Westinghouse and direct current electricity,
uh,
controlled by Thomas Edison.
Both of them as corporate leaders and a Yale didn't fully give up on direct
current,
uh,
technology until about 1985.
Uh,
there were dorm rooms where the lights were actually run on direct current
generated in a plant over near where the swing dorms are now.
MMM.
I'll leave it to sections for you to Parse this out.
It's actually a very interesting story.
The advantage of direct current electricity is it can't kill you.
It doesn't matter how much.
It's not going to kill you.
Uh,
the disadvantage of direct current electricity is that as you put it through a
long transmission wire,
you lose most of it after the first five miles.
So,
uh,
Edison control direct current electricity and wanted to make the government
regulate it in.
So what did he do?
He stressed safety.
And so if Edison had one,
there would have been a generating plant about every five miles all over the
country in every urban neighborhood,
its own generating plant.
And how did he dramatize that?
Yes.
The electric chair.
Exactly.
He,
Eh,
he put forward the view that,
well,
Westinghouse has a great technology we're going to do is kill people and
actually did demonstrations on animals and all that sort of,
there's just awful.
Uh,
but ultimately it was a case where the unregulated market one,
the government stayed out of it and alternating current from the point of view
of illuminating,
uh,
our classroom is pretty efficient.
Then you get petrochemicals and digital networks.
This is all very stylized as diagram.
But the point is that monopolies by one after another,
after another get winkled out by these changes in the underlying technology.
Okay.
Right.
New Haven at one time was arguably the leading manufacturing city for horse
drawn carriages.
Well,
it was over and over pretty suddenly.
Regulatory Capture,
a regulatory capture means what it says.
And there's a basic political sciency kind of a thesis about this,
which is that regulatory agencies,
uh,
get captured by the companies they regulate.
That if I'm a,
a bank or a brokerage,
I'm intensely interested in the sec
and I develop friendly relations with it.
I feed information to its,
its staff.
It staff comes to rely on me after spending a cycle of four,
eight years in a politically appointed position in the regulatory agency,
it occurs to people that they might pursue a career in the industry they've been
regulating.
And so there gets to be a reciprocal relationship there,
which allows a dominant firm to enjoy some advantage from its relationship with
the regulator.
Um,
the,
the current crisis in banking is a little different from this and it's not
really monopolistic,
but it is not unfair to suppose that Goldman Sachs has enjoyed a fruitful
relationship to the federal government in the last four or five decades.
And that there have been very few times when there wasn't a Goldman Sachs
partner in a position to influence a key decisions.
The more classic story would be the airlines.
When I told you where,
um,
Twa Pan Am and all the others of that era,
uh,
had this monopolistic relationship created by airline regulation and what killed
them was that enjoying the monopoly relationship to,
uh,
the,
airline regulators allowed them to be pretty soft.
They didn't have to control costs.
They could waste 15 cents of every dollar in profits and still look great to
their investors.
But when deregulation came,
the legacy costs,
uh,
were lethal to many of these firms because they were up.
Now they were up against airlines like southwest,
which had no legacy costs and ran very efficiently.
Finally,
antitrust,
uh,
antitrust emerges in states with the Sherman Antitrust Act of 1890.
Uh,
and is there is a continuous oscillation in government policy here and in most
other market economies between strict and not so strict interpretation of what
counts as a monopoly and what kind of counts as predatory monopolistic behavior.
When we get to cases,
we will see several specific instances of this
falling rate of profit.
Uh,
remember those of you who were here,
the first class,
the slides that contrasted,
uh,
labor intensive production.
And for example,
I had to JAKKS pulling a plow in Tibet juxtaposed to a,
uh,
20 ton John Deere tractor,
tilling earth in Minnesota,
Iowa or some such place.
And on the one side you had relatively low production per labor hour and on the
other,
uh,
and enormously a high rate of production per labor hour.
But based on outlays,
uh,
capital outlays for the equipment like the John Deere tractor,
well into six figures.
Yeah,
the Marxist idea.
I've got a better chart here.
Um,
the Marxists idea of how capital makes money from Labor is that capital,
that Labor is a commodity and the Labor theory of value more of us applies to
that commodity.
So how much do you have to pay for the commodity,
which he calls Labor power are laboring power?
Well,
you have to pay what it costs to feed the worker,
to close the worker,
uh,
to rear his or her children.
Uh,
you have to it,
the analogy is imagine you have a plow horse.
What's it cost you to maintain the plow horse?
Well,
that same reasoning,
Mark's applies to the workforce and you pay wages that are broadly consistent
with that.
So in my diagram,
we make sure it's right.
The laboring power is represented by the blue and capital pays labor that much,
uh,
for its activity.
The total pie represents how much value is produced by labor and what's leftover
is called surplus value.
And capital.
The capital capitalist firm keeps the surplus value by that means exploit's
labor.
And by that means increase its increases itch wealth to create wealth.
Now
that leaves out a lot.
One thing it leaves out is the fundamentals of supply and demand for labor.
Um,
it
doesn't take into account the idea that Labor would be extremely cheap in this
phase.
How many people here haven't seen the demographic transition?
Good,
because we did it a couple of days ago,
but I never know about turnover.
Um,
so Mark's is oblivious to that.
Except how would he answer if I said that?
He would say,
well,
no,
uh,
labor is cheaper in these conditions because the US socially shared expectations
for how well they have to be fed,
clothed and their children reared our law in those conditions.
So village India,
the cost of labor power is vastly less than it is in midtown Manhattan.
Okay,
that's,
that's one issue.
Another issue,
this is the age curve and it's just an an embellishment of the demography.
Another is how hard people work.
This is a Broil braggle 16th century picture of agricultural labor,
which by the evidence there is not very intense
and the,
the idea that you pay for what you get in labor is a powerful one.
And the so called scientific management movement of a century ago,
which grew up around large manufacturing companies in the u s and Europe,
was that you develop incentives to make people work really hard.
The simplest case was Henry Ford's $5 $5 a day salary,
which was way above market prices,
but allowed him to be very choosy about his workers to demand very intense labor
and to demand that they allow him to inspect their lives.
He had a,
what he called sociologists who went around to people's houses looking for
alcohol or devices for gambling and so on.
Uh,
but intensity of labor is another variable that needs to be thought of.
Now I just made that story sound really sensible,
I think,
right?
But the logic of it has always escaped me,
The notion that Labor is different from any other standard for measuring value
and that you can,
you attribute to labor the whole pie,
but actually you've got attribute much of the pie to capital and beyond capital.
You've got to attribute much of it to ownership and intellectual to management
and intellectual property knowhow,
the ability to actually make widgets well and effectively at low costs.
All that is left out of Marxists story.
He assumes he just says necessary labor time,
uh,
and draws attention away from what capitalism is best at,
which is again,
and again revising the way we produce something.
The way we distributed,
the way we design it,
the way we designed the machinery that creates it.
Even the way we designed the machinery that designs the product.
All of that is marginalized in a Marxist analysis.
And for that reason,
uh,
Marxism does not function well in analyzing a real companies in real markets.
Now the surplus value that can be extracted depends on how much labor is used in
production.
And as total labor used in production goes towards zero,
the opportunity to exploit workers goes away and with it,
profit with it,
profits have to fall.
Okay.
Now and from that follows the immiseration to working class.
Look at this bottling plant
where the work is to sit at this control panel and adjust the process plus a
little maintenance.
If any of you been in a plant where there were virtually no workers present,
can you hand him the mic?
This
sort
of putting them into bags and then they're like
Rudy sitting at sqream
exactly.
Other examples in the back.
Can we get,
um,
get a mic back to the very last row?
Wow.
Gee.
Now if you're a factory in China,
uh Huh.
Uh,
I mean it's fairly well
for guys
that were with checking this,
so very high degree of automation.
Okay.
I would,
some years ago in a textile factory in Turkey,
which covered six acres of interior manufacturing space and every,
every square foot of it was either a,
an aisle between machinery or machinery and virtually all the machinery was
working and the cloth was coming out in bolts like this at 10 or 12 different
points.
And automata were throwing it on conveyor belts and conveyor belts were,
uh,
taking it where it needed to be for shipping and labeling it and having it ready
to go.
And when I was there,
there were about six people in the plant,
uh,
all of them technicians.
Uh,
and the story about the plant was that it could operate that way for as much as
60,
60 hours.
And then there would be a shutdown for a few hours of maintenance and then an
adjustment and then another 60 hours and so on.
Uh,
another historical example is the bond sock.
Cigarette machine cigarettes were not popular before the bond sock cigarette
machine and the bonds like cigarette machine could make 6,000 cigarettes per
hour,
which they are now much better than that.
There are 100,000 an hour,
but at 6,000 per hour with zero labor cost,
uh,
it occurred to the people who formed American tobacco that they could make an
awful lot of money if they created a marketing end that would allow them to pump
all those thousands of cigarettes out into the market.
And they did it and did a very good job of it.
But at the core of it was this little piece of technology,
continuous production paper and,
and uh,
tobacco leaf go in one end of the machine and cigarettes neatly stacked in
consecutive order come out the other.
So capital intensivity takes labor out of the picture.
So in effect,
the dead,
who created the machinery or the producers,
uh,
inevitable revolution and advanced capitalist societies.
The idea here is that with
falling rates or capital and the immiseration,
the working class,
this system ceases to be stable.
And this is a guy named Georgie plucking off and plucking off was a Marxist who
was a follower of Lennon's and he's famous for having asked the question,
if the revolution is inevitable,
why must we fight and die to make it happen?
Right.
And that's an interesting question and it's,
it gets the name plaque and offs pair a paradox.
Uh,
and of course the answer to it is that the revolution wasn't inevitable and
where it did happen,
it didn't happen for the reasons Mark's described.
Where did,
where were the most advanced systems where you would expect the capital
intensive production falling rate of profit,
uh,
and low wages to labor?
Where were those systems?
What's name a few countries?
Yes,
US,
UK,
Germany,
the u s and those are not the places where the revolution happened.
It happened,
uh,
most dramatically in,
Russia and then by conquest in the rest of the Soviet Union and Cuba.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
this is Fidel on the right and Che Guevara on the left there was the,
I have a photograph in my collection at home of Fidel Castro at the new haven
train station.
And a new haven policemen looking at him like he's from Mars.
And it was just after the revolution when they hadn't,
when the break where the u s hadn't really hardened and he was on a university
tour speaking on college campuses,
trying to raise money for the revolution.
Uh,
Cuba was not an advanced capitalist economy and still is the best thing you can
say about you.
I've been twice and had been a guest of the government want.
And the best thing you can say for them is that they actually have done a
splendid job with rudimentary public health.
So that on the longevity dimension of the data automation we looked at,
if you'll screen it up tonight,
you'll discover a little green moon way,
way high side outlier on longevity.
And that's Cuba.
On the other hand,
they are dirt poor
China,
not an advanced industrial economy.
When this,
when the revolution occurred,
okay.
Then Swayla an oil state and whether they're,
what revolution has occurred or not is open to question.
And this at the height of the Cold War was the way the chessboard looked,
where Red Meant Marxist and uh,
and pink meant sort of Marxist.
And the,
the game of controlling emerging market countries was at the core of cold war
strategy or very near it.
Uh,
the theory of the universal class.
If the aristocracy,
a exploits serfs in a medieval European society and capitalists exploit
proletarians in capitalist society and proletarians come to power,
who are they going to exploit?
There's no one below them since there's no one below them.
They are the universal class and exploitation is over
now
please.
So the reasoning is like the eastern division of the American League
and Baltimore is the universal class because there's no one,
they can be
the,
the what's at the core of this last thing.
And,
and it is truly dangerous reasoning is that the universal class being in a
position superior,
no other class brings an end to exploitation.
Well,
and since that's true,
the state can wither away.
Now,
uh,
it doesn't happen in a hurt.
And behind this is a really fundamental issue of principal agency.
Did we talk about principal agency a few days ago?
Maybe not.
Well let's just for simplicity,
let's suppose the people on the country and the communist government is the
agency that they have elected to choose or which has chosen itself to manage the
country on behalf of the people.
The principal agency problem,
which occurs in things as small as a grocery store is that the employees agents
choose instead of serving the purposes of the owners or the country choose to
serve purposes of their own.
And the invariable fact about state socialism was that the people at the top of
the state apparatus,
a privileged themselves and their children
and a new class struggle developed.
Now more generally.
Uh,
and here I'm using the work of a,
a sociologist named Ralph Dahrendorf economic sociologist who died just a few
weeks ago.
Uh,
and Dahrendorf point,
which I'm sure is true,
is that you can generate classes around any process of production and
distribution.
There is nothing final about the proletariat coming to power.
And there is never a time in human history when we'll be done with the
possibility that those who control the direct levers control them not to the
benefit of others but to the benefit of themselves.
Yeah,
and so Francis Fukuyama who famously wrote a book called that had had the
punchline,
the end of history after the Cold War ended,
his view was that capitalist democracy became the end of history,
the unchangeable end point.
And of course that's not true.
The course of history is not contrary to Mark's a determinant.
Mark's was not only wrong about his own ability to understand the course of
future history.
He was wrong about the very concept that there could be a deterministic theory
which told us what was going to happen in the future.
This guy,
Schumpeter who I know you hate the way he writes,
but he understood that point profoundly and I'm out of time so I'm not going to
elaborate him.
I'll do it at the beginning of class next time.
But the guy who comes to center stage next time is f a Hayak who's most famous
book was called the Constitution of liberty.
And who believed that a market society had within it the capacity for enormous
creativity and growth.
And we'll examine that in class on Wednesday.